have you been trying to lose weight with
diet and exercise but are not seeing the
results dr nash and total transformation
who is sponsoring this next segment they
can help let's start with her client
david
dr nash was my last shot at losing
weight i went from a 42 to a 32 and lost
66 pounds in six months wow dr nash
first off welcome to the show and we
just saw dave and i actually jotted this
down because he said something he said
dr nash was my last shot at losing
weight and i think that is so key i
think so many people try diet and
exercise and all these different things
they don't get the results they come to
you and they do why is that
and they do but i'm like their last stop
on that road because they're so
frustrated they're doing everything
they're told to do to get the weight to
come off and the body's not responding
and it's because for more than 70 of
people who are overweight or obese it's
damage that's driving the weight problem
not how much they eat or move and that
was certainly true with dave one of the
things you talked about before is fatty
liver now would dave have an issue with
fatty liver and
why does fatty liver prevent someone
from losing weight so the problem is the
liver is the main organ that turns your
body fat into the fuel you burn so think
of fatty liver kind of like a clogged up
toilet jc if i've got a clogged up
toilet it can't do the conversion so
when people tell us to lose weight to
fix fatty liver it's absolutely not true
it is reversible but you have to do the
right thing when we did it to him the
weight just dropped off all around that
midsection
so how can someone tell if they have
fatty liver how do you discover this one
of the best things you can do at home to
determine if you have fatty liver is to
determine if you're in the obese
category that means a body mass index or
bmi over 30 and for men if you're bigger
than 40 inches around the tummy for dave
he came to me at a 42 and he left at a
32 so he reversed it but that's how
you're gonna tell take your waist
measurement and your bmi if those are
both positive it means you've got some
phase of fatty liver well can diet and
exercise be the simple cure to this no
because for a lot of times it's what
we're eating as well as how much we're
eating that's driving the problem so for
so many americans they're being told to
eat less and move more and it doesn't
convert the liver at all and so as a
result they don't burn very much body
fat the liver doesn't get turned around
they get frustrated and they give up
that's the cycle that we want to stop
now if someone feels like they have an
issue with fatty liver should they go
see a doctor first for a program or this
is something that you can help fix
well here's the frustrating part about
that jc if we have a fatty liver we go
to our doctor there is no drug or
medical treatment for it so they're not
going to be able to give you any answers
it is reversible but you have to know
specifically what to do to get it to
reverse and it's not weight loss your
weight has nothing to do with it you
have the answers dr nash and every time
you come to the show you do bring a
special what's the special we have for
us this week in order to do that online
evaluation with me and talk to me it's
normally 97 but when you see me on las
vegas now with jc of course i'm going to
bring you guys some kind of way to talk
to me at a much less price so we've set
aside a few spots available about 10
where you can do it for 9.97 so figure
out your bmi measure your belly and then
make that appointment but do it online
because that's where you're going to get
the special offer
thank you to dr dash in total
transformation for sponsoring this
segment take advantage of her special
offer visit her online at dr nash dot
com forward slash eval las vegas now
we'll be right back